this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to audit.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like pressing code Joey
and get 10 off delivered right to your
house what's happening you [__]
Savages it's Monday the 24th of April
the joint is brought to you by better
help listen sometimes you don't even
want to get out of bed I know much less
drag yourself out all the way to
therapist's office better helps online
therapy can further your journey to
self-discovery from wherever you are if
you could do therapy from the comfort of
your own home or while literally sitting
in bed listen I just realized uh
recently this pandemic really messed up
a lot of people not just me not just you
so do yourself a favor if you're feeling
a little low still
go get help with better help Dana help
me in ways that I can't thank Eva
so the down good better help is is
convenient flexible and suited to your
schedule no having to drive to a sterile
office or sit awkwardly in a waiting
room before your session just fill out a
brief questionnaire and get matched with
a licensed therapist and get on your way
to a better life discover your potential
with better help visit betterhelp.com
Diaz Diaz to get 10 off your first month
that's betterhelp.com
Diaz the joint is also brought to you by
Let's Talk About Sex baby moochu when
you're younger it seems like you're
always ready on the go but when you get
old like me though it's more difficult
to keep the soldier up and full
attention enter comes Bluetooth the
online service that delivers chewable
erectile dysfunction medicine right to
the privacy of your door with the same
active ingredients as Viagra Cialis or
Levitra but at a fraction of the cost
you'll be ready to go whatever the
opportunity arises and remember
Insurance ain't covering Viagra no more
it's allows a pill [__] them that's why
Bluetooth is Here sign up at bluetu.com
consult one of their licensed medical
providers and once you're approved
you'll be slinging dick within days with
your prescription Bluetooth tablets are
made in the USA you and shipped in a
discreet package so even your mailman
won't feel that's how good Bluetooth
works the mailman tries to clip those
things blue shoe wants to help you have
better sex and sling dick like a 10-foot
giant Discovery options at bluetooth.com
chew it and do it and we got a special
deal for our listeners you ready I'm
gonna hook you up with Bluetooth for
free for one month
with a promo code you ready for this
write it down Joey at checkout just pay
offend for shipping and that's
bluetooth.com promo code Joey to receive
your first month for free enough with
the sponsor let's get this party started
the joint is in full effect [__]
foreign
[Music]
ERS it's a beautiful Monday the 24th of
[__] April tremendous one more week
and the book comes out that's it Monday
Tuesday May 2nd the book comes out this
week is the last week of the [__]
month so we gotta end the month strong
April showers bring May flowers so get
ready to sling some [__] dick it was
a very interesting month I tell you I
did more this month I roughed it more
this month than I have in the last three
years and I'm happy I did guys you know
sometimes uh your life gets too easy and
you say to yourself [__] I need
something to throw me off but if I
roughed it this I haven't roughed it
like this in three [__] years so this
is the best month I've had in three
[__] years I shot Law and Order I
couldn't sleep in the hotel I thought I
was gonna [__] die I [__] walked
to the set everything worked out and
then the trip to Austin was just
listen guys I didn't want to get on a
[__] plane
and I know I've been saying this for the
last [__] two years
but it was time it was time to get out
of you got to get out of your comfort
zone from time to times in life it can't
be all
[__] uh you know waking up and the
sun's out you got to do something
different even if you don't want to do
it sometimes you have to force yourself
to do [__] even when you don't want to
[__] do it and
I didn't want to go to I'll tell you all
week I was like but I really wanted to
go down there I really really wanted
to go see what Joe had done it wasn't
about the podcast it wasn't about
smoking weed it wasn't about any of that
[__]
I had to promote the book the book
company was breaking my balls about
going down there
and you know he opened the club and he
worked so hard and I just wanted to go
down there and see what he did and I'll
tell you what
I'm happy I [__] did man for starters
you know
like I was telling you guys about a
month ago you can't open up YouTube
without [__] hate videos you know
every day it's Brendan this guy hates
this guy this podcast hates this podcast
you know there's so much hate to be
[__] going around so I don't know
what's going on at the time but I do see
a lot of from time to time I see Rogan
hate mail you know
and I go you know if they only really
knew if they only really knew thank God
Joe doesn't say a lot of his personal
[__] unlike me I'm a [__] idiot Joe
keeps a lot to himself a lot of Aces
close to his heart
or whatever the [__] the expression is
right and uh
it was just good to see what he did he
made what I called it after a three-day
assessment in my mind because I'm the
type of guy to listen
I'm not going to be able to give you a
fair assessment about anything it's like
listening to an album for the first time
it sounds good you know but let me
listen to it a few times with me I need
to see it and then process it and after
three days I'll tell you what I'm gonna
process for you guys
and this isn't really listen when I'm
talking I'm sorry about this this is for
the consumer as much as other Comics but
it's The Comedy Store on steroids
that's all I could say
Aerosmith is Aerosmith Guns and Roses is
Aerosmith on steroids if you really
think about it there's just one level of
more explosiveness this is what this
Comedy Store is uh this comedy
mothership is
it's for the comic
you know guys and I and you're like
sitting at home going what do you mean
for the comic okay
there's a lot of comedy clubs that you
go to and they never thought about the
comedian they never thought about a
green room
The Green Room is the most important
[__] room in that comedy club because
that's the last minute where a comic
collects his thoughts
some comedy clubs you go to don't even
have a green room
you sit in the guys off this smelling
chicken cutlets uh his cats looking at
pictures of his ugly [__] family you
know half these clubs don't give a [__]
when you go to those clubs you go very
interesting you know I've been to clubs
the grand opening you know what a green
room is a green room is [__] like uh
when you're going to court that room
they put you in when you're in your
orange [__] uh it's the same [__]
[__] that's not a green room we work
with it we bad with it we work around it
you know when you go to the Pabst
Theater of Milwaukee that's a [__]
green room they got a pool table they
got a [__] uh uh a [__] did you
know that in in the perhaps theater they
have not a jukebox a [__] turntable
and a wall of albums every album every
[__] mates you can play they have an
espresso bar with an espresso chick
there waiting for you they have they put
out every type of [__] food this is
whether it's a little guy or a [__]
Louis C.K or Dave Chappelle they do the
same thing for everybody so it's a
pleasure to go back there okay the sound
that Joe Rogan's is [__] phenomenal
okay I'm not one of these listen I'm
deaf
I'm deaf so everything sounds the same
to me you know what I'm saying but from
the stage what I heard out in that
audience and how it came out
it was tremendous the the sound is great
the [__]
the stage was great but the most
important thing about it listen they
just got there
uh they're still high off the you know
that they're high these people that are
working there are high like that [__]
not high on weed or high on drugs but
it's a high to working now they've been
telling me who's been going into the
last two weeks it's like [__] endless
who goes in there from Bill Byrd or Dean
Del Rey the [__] Roseanne Barr I mean
it's just the people Dave Chappelle some
[__] people from Sports World were
down there last week just to watch a
comedy show somebody from Memphis or
something it's it's uh he did
something really good for the comics he
invested in comedy he didn't invest in
himself he's got 300 000 million dollars
what's he give a [__] about he did he
made an investment for comics for all
you [__] haters out there for you
people who know somebody who hates him
covid whatever the [__] guys it's all
[__]
you know and that's you know when he
went to El Nido when I took him to El
Nido he wrote a report about El Nido he
wrote like a he put a picture up and
I'll never forget this thing he wrote he
goes I'm paying attention to the uh
to all the little things that they do at
El Nido you know they do little things
you could see it it's just it's amazing
when you go to oneido sometimes because
you what they do with food is [__]
tremendous and it's all to the T you
know it's all fresh and so he wrote
something about that and I didn't look
at it from that perspective but that's a
perspective he looks at things from
he looks at like when he looked at that
comedy club he was like I don't want it
to just be a comedy club I want it to be
the best [__] there's an elevator in
that [__] I was taking that
elevate I'm not walking up all those
[__] stairs I just did PRP in it but
it's great to see you know the last 10
years guys listen I'm not gonna lie to
you I'm a [__]
I'm a criminal when I walk into a
theater and the people like oh you know
Al Capone performed here 18 years ago
and look at this piece of art it's all
great I just came to make these
[__] laugh and to pick up a
check I didn't come here to look at
[__] art I really did I mean I'm a
[__] animal I really don't care what
the [__] just get me to the stage let me
loose let me go make him laugh let's
grab this [__] up get a check
and get the [__] out of there when I
went to Rogan's I was paying attention
to all the small details he did so many
there's a bar downstairs called mitzi's
that's beautiful
just for the [__] comics
you know just for the comics to go down
there and not feel pressured with other
people
he did all those little things you know
he's very very [__]
serious when it comes to that Green Room
people don't understand what a green
room is
he took it to the point where you can't
get in there unless you got a [__]
coat
there's no just walking in you're not
gonna walk in and he made it clear like
agents and this and I don't want you up
here I don't want you up here
commiserating taking energy from these
[__] people stay outside go to the
bar if you're not performing and that's
what a green room is I love doing the
Sony theater I love it I love it I hope
to go back next year I [__] love the
place the only thing I'm going to change
is what was going on in my green room
when I get down I don't want to see
anybody down there from now on I don't
want to see anybody down there say no
[__] party the same Rick James down
there giving out Quaaludes it's just
people getting ready for a comedy show
and people want to go down there and
mess with them thinking that that's what
I don't want to see nobody I don't see
nobody yeah yeah you're here take a seat
get a cocktail and relax I need to see
you before the show these people that
come down we want to wish you luck get
the [__] out of here I've done this 10
million [__] times I don't want to
know look sit in your seat and I'll see
you afterward we'll jump up and down
that's Peace of Mind guys
that little green room is and I realized
that this week what
when I was doing the Sony theater I
would get that I'd be aggravated
I'd be [__] aggravated why would I
I'm going to make people laugh why don't
want to get [__] aggravated for so
that's it I'm Banning [__] that's it
that's the way you do it when I was
doing the improvs with Lee and all this
[__] it was just me and Lee in the room
maybe the other comedian just talking
all of a sudden since I moved to Jersey
everybody wants to go to the Green Room
no and I realized how important it was
I'm gonna tell you what Rogan did
not only did he hold the Green Room
sacred
he put a chair by both stages
because you have so much going on before
you go on stage and they'll tell you the
lights on the light means you need to
walk up to the stage when you walk up
the stairs to the [__] stage
you know the people go okay uh you need
anything you're like no I got my water
when you sit there those last three
minutes before you go up that's your
world
everything else is background music
that's your last three minutes
of alone time of time that you could
focus on what you want to say what you
want to do you get over your nervousness
you smoke that last cigarette you do
whatever the [__] you do as a
superstitious and you go up on stage but
even that and it's not a two million
dollar chair
it's a simple chair just a [__] table
chair
that's it that's all you need and he's
got a pad there and a piece of paper
there's cigarettes there's weed there's
everything there in case you need it
he's prepared
that does something to you you know I
told people for years I I did a thousand
[__] movies
these movies were on last week a couple
you guys reached out to me the Dick Van
Dyke movies I did two Lifetime movies
with Dick Van Dyke I thought I did one I
did two of them
and I'll never forget this they didn't
pay me scale was I angry not at all
that's what the job paid they're a
company this is what they do
but the thing that made me happy about
them was when you walked into the into
the [__] dressing room that was a
basket
there was a basket
whatever a bottle of wine a t-shirt a
box of crackers some [__] you know uh
Vermont's favorite cheese tastes like
[__] yeah it's the same [__] but just a
thought
just a thought it makes you feel so much
better
it makes you feel
okay I'm appreciated
I'll work that extra 10 minutes I'll do
this I'll jump off a cliff for the shot
because they appreciated me you know
many times I walked into a comedy room
or something they don't give a [__]
listen neither do I I'm there to pick up
a check I'm not there to [__] analyze
your [__] Hospitality but I make a
mental note of it
you have to you're making them a lot of
money you're making money with them
and there's some people don't give a
[__] you go up to Nebraska you go to the
Funny Bone in in Nebraska and uh
whatever her names I can't think of her
name now she treats you like a king I
can tell you there's eight comedy club
Owners that treat you like a king then
there's 35 of them that you don't even
see for the weekend
you know you can't even come down a
Thursday night and shake my hand there's
all those little things Rogan lives at
that club
he lives at that club he lives at that
club he's that a welcome people you know
the [__] hotel he puts the comics in
a tremendous you don't have to hear
people yelling in the middle of night
because everybody's trying to save 10
bucks
but by saving those 10 bucks you've
turned that guy off
he's not going to come back
you know that's the most important thing
is feeling
appreciated that's all I really want to
feel that's it I don't want you to kiss
my ass I don't want you to feed me
grapes I don't want you to lick my balls
I don't want you to do nothing I just
want to feel like you were happy that I
was there
I mean for me I don't give a [__] I'm
gonna go there and take your money
anyway but
it just gives you you know what next
time I'll come here I'm gonna [__]
write more I'm gonna be a lot better for
these people because the club is great
and that's what makes a big difference
in comedy man it's not the money they
pay you I could if I did this for money
guys
you crazy I did this to be funny all
those years and Through the Years you
meet different people you talk with
different people and you see what works
and what doesn't work for you I gotta
tell you something [__] Rogan did it
with this one he really [__] did and
Austin as far as Austin as a city
I didn't recognize him
I remembered a few spots
it's growing they really listen man
growth is beautiful thing to see some
people don't want to see growth
some people knows what what comes with
growth you know
around the corner from where I was
staying they're building the biggest
building in Texas
it's going to be a high rise like you're
not going to you know you can't see the
state capital from everywhere now
they've built so much in the last two
years I mean they've done you know and
it's going to be the capital for comedy
I I am
convinced after what I saw this week
it's the capital for comedy if you're a
young comic and you want to learn the
business from A to Z I'm not talking to
move down there to hang out with Joe
Rogan I'm talking about the cat they got
the key Creek in the cave
they've got helium coming they've got
Cap City who else the Vulcan the Sunset
Strip Comedy Room and a thousand other
other places that do comedy if you're
serious really serious about kind of
you're just like oh you know I I get it
but if you're serious about your trade
and about your art and you really want
to improve and really want to see it
from the inside out
that's the [__] town to do it
you know everybody always listen when
you went to L.A to find riches and all
that [__] most of these people that go
there later to find riches they'll tell
you
that's not really a market
for transitioning somebody said
something to me interesting years ago
when I got the longest yard my agent
called them to put me on a radio show
and the guy said we're not in business
of making Stars we just put stars on
here
I was mad for about 10 minutes I
understood that I understood where he
was coming from and I got it that guy
calls me today to do work for him I will
not do work for him his partner calls me
all the time because he got thrown off
the radio and he's he's an idiot anyway
but he was cool like that you know I'm
not in the business of making Stars well
that's the problem with LA everybody
goes that light to be a star and
everybody forgets what they went there
for which is [__] comedy
you know if I took away the podcast and
if I took away movies and film and
television I took away anything and I
just focused on stand up
it would be scary
because I was scary with everything
going on
could you imagine if you withdraw
everything and just focus on stand-up
like a Dave Chappelle people want to
know why Dave Chappelle is so good you
don't have to do 10 podcasts a week you
don't see Ali Wong doing a podcast you
know we just jumped on it we thought it
was the hip thing to do it don't work
for people but look at the people that
just focus on stand up
when you start stand up you want to be
around people who just focus on stand up
fake people in your Open Mic scene
that's why you go to a better Open Mic
scene you started your Open Mic scene
they give you a little [__] you get
kicked in the head a few times you get
drunk in public nobody wants to [__]
talk to you no more
you got to move to another [__] open
my city and that's where you get
strengthened I started in Denver but I
strengthened up in Seattle that's why I
became a [__] feature act and then I
moved to Los Angeles which made my Trek
a lot easier now listen crystalia walked
into the comedy store the first time and
got on stage
God bless him you know I'm not mad at
Chris for that I know a lot of people
who started in Los Angeles and they're
very successful today but when you look
at how many to compare to success you'll
go yeah I get it it's a small percentage
why it's such a and you know you you
play as a as a as a human being as a
comedian as a business person you play
percentages
where can I be the strongest that I
could be if I move to LA I'm going to be
at 10 but if I move to a city like
Seattle to develop I'm going to be at 50
there's more of a chance for me to grow
there there's more of a chance to meet
more people to start from the ground
floor with a Booker
in L.A people run out there to be famous
and to be rich and to be Superstars and
they run into that now guys you go
somewhere else and develop you look you
read all these I was reading somebody's
story the other day they were doing a
traveling [__] theater until six
years ago
you know whatever what's that thing
called when you go from town to town and
do like I don't know some [__] uh no
like a production like a production of
I don't know Chicago that travels across
the country like you do two it's like
Comedy Tour a second Comedy Tour you
know can you imagine doing that for
acting the acting strength that you're
going to come out they've always said
that when you do theater
if you really want to do acting like if
you really want to act
not be famous you got to break all this
[__] up not be on hanging on with Jay
Leno and hanging on Jimmy Kimmel if you
just want to learn to act
you can do a play
but Joey don't pay nothing pays crime
Pace in the beginning but that don't pay
that's not gonna [__] pay you in the
beginning you're gonna get ten dollars a
week plus per diem but the money doesn't
matter if you really love acting
if you really love stand up like I love
stand up I did in the beginning I
[__] I didn't care about money I
didn't get into this to be [__] rich
I got into this to [__] do something
with my life and God forbid I stuck with
it and something happened you know what
the percentages of that are you know if
you play percentages what are they what
are they for me to really start in
Boston move to New York develop and then
become a big [__] comedy star in L.A
the percentages are against you but if
you got heart and balls and if you do it
correctly and work smart
I was a stupid [__] but for some
reason with comedy I learned how to work
smart for years I was just a irikawa you
know like some [__] crazy Indian
it's when you start working smart and
start
planning your [__] moves
that you see that growth immediately
listen with Jiu Jitsu I was going to
Jujitsu [__] four years in L.A I was
getting beat up every [__] day I
still get beat up every day here but the
same thing happened with my Jiu Jitsu
lately since I don't have to do 10
podcasts a week get on a plane on
[__] Thursday write comedy do all
this [__] I'm absorbing more Jujitsu
because it's Celeste I gotta focus on so
you young Comics that are doing a
podcast early on and it's doing stand up
listen
it's great I think you're doing the
right [__] thing because whether your
podcast succeeds or not at least you
tried it at least you know what the [__]
is going on and if it don't work your
second or third year in comedy I
guarantee you one thing
it'll work your 70 in comedy because
you're more experienced you know what
more to do I'm very happy how I picked
apart my career you know I see a lot of
comics now
putting improv sets on Instagram
listen I'm not mad at you you do what
the [__] you want it's your career but
nobody wants to pay 25 to see a game of
chance
do you follow him saying to you don't
get me wrong the first three years of
Comedy I spoke to the audience and then
when I moved to New York that's a really
bad habit that you pick up in New York
speaking to the [__] audience okay
when these people put up these reels
they're speaking to the audience it's
great you're getting on stage I'm proud
of you
but everybody's doing that [__] why are
you putting that real up of you talking
to the audience when everybody's doing
crowd work [__] Chronicles if you
want people to come see you you wanna
you know no Miss Pat does crowd work
Chronicles or something like that and
it's great I love Miss Pat but I see a
lot of younger Comics trying to do the
same thing and
put upsets with you doing straight
comedy never mind that you don't want
them seeing you do that [__] that's what
everybody's doing but the people that
are doing I've been doing for 15 years
you're trying to do that three years
so it makes do you follow him saying
there's steps to this [__] thing that
step to this [__] do you
understand me but anyway you pick your
own decisions back to the Rogan thing I
uh
I love a lot of comedy clubs there's
some great comedy clubs in the country I
love Cleveland
[__] Milwaukee I love uh
Club up in [__] uh
kind of a Vermont not Vermont
I don't even know whether up by Boston
up there may not Maine the other town
it's got a great
Providence Rhode Island that's a great
[__] club the guy gives a [__] about
you you know the stand Patrick they do
you know they [__] the Gotham is
[__] great they take care a lot of
clubs you walk into they [__] they go
out of their way they at least show that
you're a little [__] happy and that's
all I've ever wanted we'll end with that
real quick I got a break for a sponsor
break here give me three minutes and
I'll be right back [__] all right
it's NBA playoff times that means big
hoop faction with DraftKings Sportsbook
the official sports betting part of the
NBA get on the excitement with the touch
of a button new customers five dollar
pregame moneyline bet you're gonna get
150 in bonus bets open the DraftKings
Sportsbook app today opt-in and place a
same game ballet on any NBA game if it
doesn't hit we're gonna get you a 10
bonus back it's that easy DraftKings you
got UFC you got pro baseball oh you got
soccer you got golf you got everything
but right now it's NBA playoff time so
download the app and sign up with code
Joey
j-o-e-y again new customers can make a
five dollar pregame moneyline bet and
score 150 in bonus bets if their team
wins only at DraftKings Sportsbook with
code Joey gambling problem called 1-800
Gambler if you're in Boston Mass call
1-800-327-5050 or visit
gamblinghelpma.org once you take care of
that download the app and let's get
ready to rock eligibility restrictions
apply see draftkings.com bonus book for
details and state specific responsible
gaming resources thank you I want to
thank DraftKings and I want to thank you
Savages we're back [__] don't
forget
DraftKings is always [__] there
for you back to the podcast anyway what
I was talking about was this I I gotta
talk about something else that was
bothering the [__] out of me I hope you
guys uh I gave you a 420 surprise the
420 surprise was me going on Joe I know
that a lot of people been bothering me
it's so weird whenever I start talking
to Joe about getting on the podcast it
never fails as soon as I hang up with
Joe I get a tweet
have you spoke to Joe layley it's time
to get you back on Rogan again like
people [__] know when it's time again
I got like 20 things I wasn't sure I was
going to be able to make it last week so
I didn't say nothing I wasn't sure I
didn't know what was going to happen I
thought I'd get to the airport and crap
out and come home and then Joe would be
mad at me but no I was decided to go
down there it was [__] great going
down there the only problem was this
guys and I've been talking about this
and I don't want to [__] harp on this
[__] but
I'm not going to be getting on a plane
for a while
I will not begin on a [__] plane for
a while you know man
I don't like to get abused I don't like
I don't like pain to get abused the
flight from Newark to Austin was
phenomenal I flew United and I flew
United on the way back I've never really
had problems were United they're not my
favorite Airline okay it's always been
like Delta JetBlue American I've always
thought of United as the last one the
problem is the United's Hub is Newark so
now I'm [__] stuck with them if I
want to fly I gotta fly [__] United
the flight home guys was basically a
[__] nightmare and for me I had done
what I went down to do I could look you
guys in the eye and tell you
I was not upset at all at all by no
means as I have said I knew this was
part of doing business but I had a
decision to make whether I want to keep
doing this or not doing this and guys
it's not for me anymore
the flight was a 6 a.m flight I couldn't
even do the second show with Joe's
because I got that I couldn't sleep that
night when you got off the plane you're
not gonna [__] sleep and then I got
up early and I had a bunch of calls to
make and radio I had to do a radio show
and [__] Reno for a friend of mine I
don't even know for that yet
I was tired but I had a six a.m flight
the car was picking me up at 4 [__]
15.
I want to at least get three or four
hours before I get on a [__] plane so
I I didn't even see red band I saw
Duncan I saw Russell Peters I saw a
[__] Mrs Segura she looked [__]
beautiful Christina P looked [__]
beautiful man I saw a lot of great
people
so I was happy but I really wanted to
stay for Red Band Red Band got stuck at
the Vulcan
I get up at four o'clock
I get up like 3 30.
I get up I check my messages nothing
more right we're ready to [__] go I
wash my [__] I drink some coffee I eat
a protein bar I get to the [__]
airport I get to the airport at 4 30 the
flight said six guys I walk in and write
down the board canceled
I go what time is the not the flight now
11. I said it's 4 30 I gotta I could eat
breakfast hang out read a little bit
I'll stay at the airport you know what
the lady told me she goes you can't I'm
not checking in until 10. so I don't
know what to tell you
that's what she told me I was like okay
well what are you gonna sit in that
[__] and if you can't pass that
[__] thing you just there's no
restaurant you gotta pass the [__]
alarm systems the the security check to
[__] do anything
so what are you just gonna sit there no
weed no roll joints I had no the Edibles
was in the [__] luggage I had nothing
to attack so I said [__] this I took an
Uber back to the hotel I didn't even
check out I never checked out I took the
card with me because they do automatic
check out anyway they realize it yeah so
I didn't check out so when I walked back
in I just said can you redo my cardigan
boom I went up to my room and I hit the
crib I got a text the plane takes off at
11. I [__] shot to the airport at 11
o'clock 10 o'clock quarter to ten
sure enough I walk in the door
plane's been moved to 11 12. okay 12
minutes ain't gonna kill nobody 11 12.
I walk through security I sit down beep
my pager goes off or whatever my text
goes off
it got pushed to 11 31. okay that's 20
more minutes no big [__] deal but I
know what's coming
got pushed to 11 48.
I got up I went over and then I went
over to uh
my [__] favorite of all time the
barbecue joint down there I forget the
name of it at the airport they haven't
met had all the [__] Houston whatever
it's called slim whatever the [__] it's
called
I'm killing time again guys I'm not
cheap I love to eat you know I'm a fat
[__] I love all this [__]
can't see so I put my glasses on
guys they wanted 25 for a brisket
platter Salt Lick Barbecue who I love
I've been eating at Salt Lick since 199
[__] seven I love Salt Lick you
understand me they wanted 25 bucks at
the end now again I'm not thinking about
me I'm thinking about you
you're two boys and your wife
it was 25 bucks for three little pieces
of brisket that were delicious [__]
tremendous
it had to be an ounce and a half of
baked beans
and an ounce and a half it was mashed
potatoes for midgets it was just a scoop
with a [__] big school straw that's
all it was
that's all they [__] gave you
six for the iced tea with no ice cubes
in it so it was 31 the [__] lunch for
me at an airport
guys you know when does the abuse end
I walked back to [__] catch my 11 48
no no no no
the plane got delayed again until 12 15.
by the time I sit in my chair the plane
got delayed again till 12 30. now they
make an announcement uh Newark people
the flight's touching down
you're in luck because the plane was
coming from somewhere else you're in
luck okay
we're gonna [__] throw everybody off
the plane and put you [__] on
thank you for your patience beautiful we
get on the plane we're ready to go
boom sit down
no lunch service
it's gonna be breakfast instead okay
it's one o'clock I already have
breakfast I had my little Salt Lick
Barbecue what do I give a [__] about
lunch I'm gonna hit the crib anyway I'm
[__] tired
and then they say no Wi-Fi
no Wi-Fi on the flight okay I watch TV
the little TV screen they have like I
brought my earphones
beautiful I [__] fall asleep you know
I woke up at three o'clock and they
still hadn't served food yet
they served the breakfast at 3 30.
they brought me a Fertitta but supposed
to be a frittata which is like eggs with
potatoes and sausages and like a little
circle tastes like dick anyway I wasn't
going to eat that I would eat the fruit
cup and maybe a piece of bread or
guys the frittata was soggy make it look
like pudding and it had like this cheese
on top of it that I was not gonna
[__] try no way nine United Airlines
so I just ate the fruit cup and I sent
it back but here's the other reason
I looked at the I went to put my [__]
you know you always want to put your
little [__] napkin on like a
professional guys when I put the napkin
on I took the silver out I looked at the
fork I never looked at the fork I never
looked I'm a [__] gorilla I don't
look at Forks to see if they clean or
not I didn't even have to look at it I
just looked down the fork still had food
on it I turned the fork around there was
food on the other side and there was
still something on the [__] knife
I was like guys this is
the all-time worst okay now do you think
I'm gonna Yelp
do you think I'm gonna call him when I
get off the plane it's not going to do
nothing I just won't fly anymore
but the lady next to me was a gentile
and a high-powered Gentile she's some
high-powered attorney and the guy behind
me was a gentile and they were just
talking about how bad this flight was
and how bad it was lately and that none
of those people on the flight had gotten
the [__] text to tell him that the
flight was delayed they were pissed
these people on the [__] playing with
me were [__] pissed and they were
mumbling but this lady next to me went
off before the plane landed
she's like I'm calling this guy I'm
calling the president of this I'm
calling this this has been she goes look
at these two [__] waitresses in first
class they have not even asked us if we
need anything the plane had turbulence
like a [__] you got to put your
seat belt on I didn't put it on just to
see if they noticed
they didn't care
they never came back there and brought
you asked you if you want anything else
they gave no water bottles they give you
a glass of water the water looks like
it's from [__] Newark which it
probably is they [__] this is the
thing you could see it like [__] you
know like when water has oil on it you
can see like vinegar and oil in layers
like that that's how the [__] water
looked so guys again I'm not gonna call
anybody I'm not gonna rant nobody out I
just made a decision
I'm not flying for a while until some
I'm told
20 000 of us get together and sign a
[__] petition or something and I'm
not even thinking about me guys I don't
need to go anywhere I don't really give
a [__] what's going on anywhere I'm
thinking about you [__] with
family people with two kids can you
imagine with your two-year-old child and
your four-year-old child going to an
airport at six a.m and they now you
gotta wait there with your kids till 11
o'clock you're like me you're a piece of
[__] you could deal with anything I
don't give a [__] what you're throwing
me but why should I put my child and my
wife through that they don't deserve
that [__] especially
at the prices that you're paying for
these [__] plane tickets I just
checked for a plane ticket the other day
I used to pay 600 for it's 1400.
just to look I just because I'm a nerd
like that I love to look at things
they're not I wasn't doing anything I
looked to see what it was it was a plane
ticket to Mexico for a friend of mine he
says he can't find nothing cheaper than
800. I said let me get a crack at it
probably about 1400 tickets to [__]
Mexico the same plane he takes
every year for the last five years
so I you know like I said guys I get it
I love you [__] I love
traveling I've been doing it for [__]
ever but
not anymore I'm giving it a break in
fact my wife even told me she goes after
that story we're driving to Nashville
we'll take our time three hours a day
four hours a day I don't give a
Frenchman's [__] listen think about this
I got to the airport at 4 30 in the
morning yesterday I didn't walk in my
door until seven
15 at night 7 20.
I could have walked the [__]
Nashville
it's 12 hours to get to Nashville think
about that
that let's start the day at six a.m
that's a 13-hour day
I kind of driven to Nashville
you know that's it I'm done I really
wanted to go out to LA and see Ryan
sickler next week
and do Bill Maher's podcast to promote
the book but you know what guys we'll do
a [__] Zoom I'm not putting myself up
to that [__] abuse it's over that's
it that's how I feel that that said for
a while unless something I feel bad my
uncle's pushing the pushing the ticket I
don't know how much time he's got left
but
I mean for that I'd have to [__] fly
out and the one thing I'd like
about the Rogan podcast this week that I
got to tell my side of the Xanax thing I
[__] loved it and I I'm getting a lot
of emails from people about it that uh
didn't know what was going on that they
got hooked on them and they went through
the same thing
I'm happy I got to tell that story I'm
really happy because it set my life it
destroyed my life for two [__] years
guys
you know uh Rogan was talking about
Jordan Peterson how it destroyed him
there's a thing I think it's called
echinacea that you get after you stop
taking those things that is basically
the worst feeling
I've ever had in my [__] life I can't
just and it was brought up every time I
took a Xanax to calm my anxiety that
feeling would start and it's a feeling
of uncertainty you can't really grasp
your heart's beating your stomach
something it's like 20 things that are
wrong
and I used to live like this guys I
don't wish this [__] on anybody it's
like I told Joe it's not that I was
doing Xanax to drink and jump up and
down I really had a really bad condition
it was not [__] good and now after
now my anxiety is that if my anxiety was
at 120 three years ago
my anxiety now is at five percent
I feel it once in a while and I just
brush through it I just go to myself at
this time is when I would insert a
[__] Xanax
these times when I feel this way but
that echinacea
I don't want to wish that on anybody
because you destroyed your central
nervous system
and when your central nervous system is
down you don't want to experience that
you know after I went through what I
went through I actually dove into this
[__] whole thing and I realized that
Xanax is just a two-week prescription
until they find what's going on with you
it's just a little Band-Aid for a few
weeks anything after that you're just
[__] killing yourself to live my
sister one of one of my tightest friends
in the world has taken his Xanax every
day for 50 years to go to sleep
and she's had no problems you know so
everybody's built differently my other
body went through what I went through
didn't know he was going through it
[__] went to see 80 doctors to get
take care of the feeling and it was like
me some assistant to the doctor figured
it out well you've still taken the Xanax
yes I am well that was two years ago
like that's how I discovered it the
ladies just said you're still taking the
Xanax yeah that was 12 years you've been
taking Xanax for 12 years ago no she
gave it they prescribed to me in 2012. I
started eating it heavy in 2018 2019 and
then the pandemic came and I went off
the [__] rails and I'm also happy I
did the Rogan podcast because I realized
the fear I had
was that La before we left I didn't you
know I didn't remember it
you know when Rogan said that he had his
liberal friends calling him to borrow
guns
I thought about that everybody was
calling everybody to borrow guns
everybody people would like you have an
extra gun I can count everybody
it was that's how scary it was and I
thought for sure you know I had a front
door with a uh
I had a front door with a [__] glass
on it
I would sit there at night with a gun
I never told nobody this
because I the neighborhood was going to
[__] guys you know when you smoke pot
with somebody three nights a week and I
would meet this girl in my office Sophia
I would meet Sophia she's my best friend
now I I would meet her at my office and
we'd smoke no when the pandemic came we
didn't want to be in close quarters so I
would meet her outside behind 7-Eleven
one night we heard gunshots that were
[__] 100 yards away from us
you know many years you know how many
times I heard gunshots in the valley
like I was here before I left the valley
I was hearing gunshots
three or four times a day three four
times a day
I was telling my wife this morning that
before we left there was a feeling of
creepiness
felt CIA induced like it was [__] that
you couldn't imagine that you were
saying I told you guys about the hooker
I told you guys about he the guy hitting
the guy with the brick uh the with the
four by four how many mornings I got up
and I would ride my bike early
and I would go by North Hollywood Park
and on the far end of the park
there'd be a box of bricks
like just a box of bricks
like somebody was just dropping off
bricks and putting them on the corners
who the [__] was doing this
you know who the [__] was doing this
[__]
this [__] was getting into my psyche
with the the Xanax and everything else
that was going on in my life that's what
put me over the top I definitely guys
a little bit it wasn't that I was
paranoid is that
listen man you could tell me anything
new [__] and want you know those
people that tell you don't go down there
you know you could tell me whatever you
want
until I make an assessment of it that's
what it is you know
guys I'm not crazy guys I'm not you know
I wasn't doing coke so it's not I was
paranoid during 2018 or the pandemic
it was what I saw
and I saw it
Quick Change
the things that stuck out to me the most
during that period was going to Burbank
one day
Burbank is a tight Disney City tight bro
they got cameras everywhere everything
in Bourbon and how many people jaywalk
and Burbank
and right before the black lives matter
movement right before
the guy got choked the guy got killed in
Milwaukee
they I was already seeing weird things
like the bricks but this was the
weirdest thing I had saw way before
black lives matter and anything in
Burbank
I saw two young African-American kids
jaywalking
and I'm like this ain't right
they don't let white people jaywalking
Burbank
never mind two young brothers that came
from somewhere
you were seeing cars
with young black kids driving around all
day and you know what they're looking
for you were seeing cars with Mexican
kids driving around all day four in a
car I was seeing cards with four white
kids in it driving around all day during
the pandemic they weren't looking to
make friends
so when you start seeing this it's like
when you do Coke when I was doing coke
if once I go into the liquor store and
once I put that coke in my pocket and I
was headed home and I was all fired up
on the way home if I saw a cop car
short had nothing to do with me nothing
to do with me he was pulling the other
way talking to some other people maybe
at 7 11 getting a coffee but just me
seeing him it would stay in my mind and
while I was doing coke I would get
paranoid about that cop why was he there
what was he drinking coffee why wasn't
he drinking milk like I would think of
all those stupid things you know that's
what happened during the pandemic I
wasn't getting high but I saw so many
dumb little [__] things that I had
never seen before in that area
see if I had seen that in San Francisco
I keep walking if I see that in North
Bergen New Jersey I keep walking if I
see that in New York City I keep walking
but Burbank
not that simple
Burbank is the town that I went to do
flatbers one night
and then when I walked out of flappers
ready for this guys 10 o'clock at night
9 30 at night I dropped my wallet
in the middle of the street it fell
I got in my car
and I'm driving home and when I got to
my house 10 minutes later I realized my
wallet was gone I had to be a plane the
next morning
I flew back the flappers went back to
the where I was parked and as I was at
the light I could see my wallet in the
middle of the street
how many cars went over that thing how
many people crossed that street from
that bar going to the parking lot nobody
picked up my wallet that's to let you
know how claim bird bank is
so for me to see two African-American
kids
that didn't look like they lived in
Burbank just walking the streets of
Burbank jaywalking that fit just was
like
it has nothing to do with me but I'll
make a mental note of that like we were
just seeing so many things it felt very
contrived and then once the thing went
down with law uh with Luke Floyd George
Floyd
it was like you were living in a [__]
dream
dream this [__] could not happen my
daughter's daycare
that place has been there 40 years
called Saint Paul's
they are the nicest Gentiles your man in
your life it was like a Protestant
whatever Presbyterian I didn't even give
a [__] they were so nice my daughter
grew so much there I knew the people who
worked there I knew the women the moms
they would come to they were all at the
same parties anytime there was a daycare
party all the people and the teachers
would go we went to uh Yankee games
together with the Dodger games together
we did all these things together as
parents and as part of That Daycare
I wake up one day to see that
it was like a plant
it could this couldn't have been true
some African-American guy after the
George Floyd thing was walking down
Studio City which you never really see
that many African-Americans in Studio
City
and he was hot so he sat
on Saint Paul's Lawn
at three o'clock when the kids were
getting out of the school and the
daycare
but he was like you know on the lawn
like with Hot Pants on on a [__]
carpet like this just didn't happen
there so when the guy that runs the
school the principal goes brother I
don't mind if you sit there just move it
over you can't lay there and put a radio
there the guy called NBC News
the school that my daughter was going to
is now under attack for racist things
when half the people in there like there
was two African-American women that
worked there there was two Mexicans that
worked there a couple white chicks that
worked there a couple Asian girls that
worked there so now they were just like
everybody was pointing them to be racist
I was like
something is not [__] right here
this is it just did not feel weird it
didn't feel real it felt very surreal
so we got with the pandemic you start
getting all of a sudden everybody
started getting canceled
remember when the pandemic hit also now
people want to start canceling people oh
I remember 10 years ago this comedian
[__] finger banged me in the shower
you know all of a sudden it didn't seem
surreal
and then all this George George Floyd
thing to this day does not seem surreal
the way he had his knee on his neck and
looking at the camera directly something
just didn't feel right to me about that
whole thing it was like something was
there was some it felt like a setup
but obviously we see it wasn't it felt
like a setup was obviously somebody lost
their lives you know I saw the tape when
the guy couldn't breathe the brother up
in the Bronx or Brooklyn when they
[__] choked him something about the
whole George Floyd thing didn't even it
didn't seem right it felt like it was a
bad dream and this happened every day
but during the pandemic it made people
go out to the streets and protest and
break [__] so it didn't feel real to me
man and I'm like I waited all this time
in my life
to [__] have a family to have a wife
to be a a good father and just to get my
life together and and now they're going
to kill my wife like that's what I was
like thinking now they're going to come
do something to my kids then I saw the
Latin King sign on the school this is
Studio City guys
they got 16 Latins up there what the
[__] are the Latin King is doing in
Studio City so it just felt so surreal
not to mention and I can tell you guys
now I went to buy a gun
I can't buy a gun I'm a felon all these
[__] and every [__] gun store had
huge lines I'm talking blocks wrapped
around like everybody was buying a gun
for the end of the world so something
about that little fear got me going and
what really scared me it felt like I was
I was gonna have to do something
that's why I was sleeping on my [__]
chair in the living room waiting for
somebody to kick the [__] door in so
I went to The Armenian and I go let me
get a gun so he brought me a nine
millimeter I need something else so he
goes I cannot get you something right
now I will just give you uh an AR-15 for
the house so I had a [__] like a
homemade machine gun in my [__]
bedroom I don't want that in my house I
don't ever want a [__] weapon like
that in my eyes I could see having a
handgun a 38 to shoot a burglar in the
leg but a [__] machine gun like dog
this thing was [__] had air pumps and
[__] his friend had put it together
you could keep it for a feet and then
when I left New Jersey guys like listen
we have connections in Jersey as soon as
you touch down in Jersey we'll have a
gun ready for you I don't need a gun in
Jersey I need it wasn't [__] L.A and
then the gun he gave me I was going to
take it on the flight and I said you
know what I don't want to bring this gun
with me to Jersey I don't want to bring
this part of my life into my jersey life
so I gave the the gun to my ex Jiu Jitsu
teacher who I still talk to all the time
didn't ask him for a dime just take it
and I came here and that's the [__]
that was what was going on in L.A before
we left and that's what I thought [__]
me up the most was that fear I wasn't
scared of him come on guys with the life
I've had you think I'm [__] scared of
anything it was more or less
I just didn't want to lose my family in
that way and that's it that's our
podcast for Monday the 24th of
[__] April this is your last
week to pre-order the book it's number
15 on Amazon you guys have made my year
with this
and you haven't made my year as much as
you made Erica florentine's year
you know she was a girl just trying to
get by and all of a sudden here we are
with a [__] great book and uh people
enthused about it so I really want to
please you guys I really want to please
you I really want to thank you guys for
uh doing this for me I know I've done a
lot of different things for a lot of you
crazy people but this is big and you're
making Erica florentine's day and that's
part of what we do here we're always
looking to make somebody's day
and that's it and that's that you got
one more week to order and then I'll
keep you posted on the [__] uh the
book signings in New York
Boston
Philly and Jersey that's all I got for
now
beside that guys uh
it was a great month
I love you [__] with all my
heart and uh I'll see you [__]
next Monday tip top Magoo ready to go
and now for a word for my [__]
sponsor Jack
I want to thank you guys thank you for
always having my back
and uh let's talk about some sponsors
first off this episode is brought to you
by better help sometimes you don't even
want to get yourself out of bed much
less drag yourself to a therapist office
I've been there I know what it feels
like better helps online therapy can
further your journey to self-discovery
from wherever you are you could do the
therapy from the comfort of your home or
literally your bed but listen all jokes
aside I was stuck for a while I
contacted Better Health and they blew my
doors out here I am better than ever
it's convenient flexible and suited to
your schedules no having to drive to
some office or sit awkwardly in a
waiting room just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and get on your way
to living a better life if you need a
different therapist at any point you
could switch discover your potential
with better help visit betterhelp.com
Diaz again that's betterhelp.com
says the joint is also brought to you by
you ready for this Bluetooth it's
summertime it's time to stink sling dick
when you're younger you're always on the
go but once you get older like me it's
difficult to keep the soldier up at full
attention you gotta smack them around a
little bit [__] that head to Bluetooth
the online service that delivers
chewable Ed medicine right to your door
with the same active ingredients as
Viagra Cialis and Levitra but at a
fraction of the cost you'll be ready to
go when that victim shows up listen to
me I love blue shoe not to mention
Viagra is 100 bucks a pill and they
don't cover by Insurance what the [__]
are you waiting for sign up at
bluetube.com consult with a licensed
medical providers and once you're
approved boom there you are big dick and
with a license and a prescription
Bluetooth tablets are made in the USA
and shipped to you in a discreet
packaging Bluetooth wants to help you
sling dick and have better self better
sex Discovery options at bluetooth.com
chew it do it and we got a special deal
for our listeners try Bluetooth free
when you use my promo code that's Joey
at checkout just pay five dollars for
shipping and that's bluetooth.com code
Joey to receive your first month for
free you'll be happy after you get it
you'll be [__] thanking me and that's
it and that's that I want to thank
DraftKings I want to thank Bluetooth and
I want to thank better help but I want
to thank you [__] for always
having my back don't forget it's the
last week to order tremendous story of a
comedy Savage
amazon.com Barnes and noblefucking
thriftbooks.com and that said I love you
[__] stay black and have a great
week
[Music]